WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO AND
GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS THE FIVE.
BUSY FRIDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIRING UP HIS BASE TODAY
WITH A ROUSING SPEECH AT
CPAC OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON,
D.C.
HE ADDRESSED A NUMBER OF
PRESSING ISSUES, INCLUDING
THE CRISIS IN OUR SCHOOLS,
NORTH KOREA, AND ALSO THE
UPCOMING ELECTIONS.
HOPING TO MOTIVATE THE CROWD
NOT TO BE COMPLACENT ABOUT
THE MID TERMS.
>> HISTORICALLY, IF YOU WIN
THE PRESIDENCY, YOU DON'T DO
WELL TWO YEARS LATER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
DON'T BE COMPLACENT BECAUSE,
IF THEY GET IN, THEY WILL
REPEAL YOUR TAX CUTS.
THEY WILL PUT JUDGES IN THAT
YOU WOULDN'T BELIEVE.
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT, WHICH WE
WILL NEVER ALLOW TO HAPPEN.
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THEY WILL TAKE AWAY THOSE
MASSIVE TAX CUTS AND THEY
WILL TAKE AWAY YOUR SECOND
AMENDMENT.
THE SENATE DEMOCRATS AND THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE TOTALLY
ABANDONED DACA.
THEY HAVE -- THEY DON'T EVEN
TALK TO ME ABOUT IT THEY
HAVE TOTALLY ABANDONED.
YOU KNOW, WE GET THE
REPUTATION LIKE DACA.
IT'S NOT REPUBLICAN.
DON'T WORRY, YOU ARE GETTING
THE WALL.
DON'T WORRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GETTING THE WALL.
>> Jesse: THERE WAS, OF
COURSE, LOTS OF TRADEMARK
TRUMP FLASH AS WELL.
>> ALL THOSE HORRIBLE PEOPLE
BACK THERE.
THEY ARE GOING TO SUPPORT
ME.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE IF SOMEBODY ELSE
WON, THEIR RATINGS WOULD GO
DOWN.
THEY WOULD ALL BE OUT OF
BUSINESS.
MY ADMINISTRATION, I THINK,
HAS HAD THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
FIRST YEAR IN THE HISTORY OF
THE PRESIDENCY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE A VERY, VERY CROOKED
MEDIA.
[CHANTING LOCK HER UP]
WHEN I WAS HERE 2011 I MADE
A SPEECH.
IT WAS A LOVE FEST, 2011 I
BELIEVE THE TIME WAS.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
REMEMBERED AND THEY SAID WE
WANT TRUMP.
WE WANT TRUMP.
BY THE WAY, WHAT A NICE
PICTURE THAT IS.
LOOK AT THAT.
I WOULD LOVE TO WATCH THAT
GUY SPEAK.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, BOY.
I TRY LIKE HELL TOLL HIDE
THAT BALD SPOT, FOLKS.
I WORK HARD AT IT.
IT DOESN'T LOOK BAD.
HEY, WE ARE HANGING.
IN WE ARE HANGING IN.
>> Jesse: WE'RE HANGING.
IN I THOUGHT, GREG, THAT WAS
THE BEST MOMENT.
SO SELF-DEPRECATING FOR
SOMEBODY THAT'S PRETTIY, I
WOULDN'T SAY VAIN BUT VERY
INVOLVED WITH HIS HAIR.
HE LOVES HIS HAIR.
AND TO MAKE THAT POINT I
THOUGHT WAS PRETTY FUNNY:
>> Gregg: I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS RECENT BUT IS HE
GOOD AT TAKING THE SLINGS
AND AIR WORRIES AND TURNING
THEM INTO ARMOR.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
NEW STEPHEN COLBERT CARTOON
ABOUT TRUMP AND HOW HARD IT
IS FOR ANTI-TRUMP COMEDIANS
TO PROSPER BECAUSE TRUMP
HIMSELF IS ACTUALLY MORE
INTERESTING.
>> Dana: CARTOON IS NOT THAT
FUNNY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE COMPETING
WITH THAT.  THAT'S ACTUALLY
FUNNIER.
IMAGINE A PORTRAIT CLASS
WHERE EVERYBODY IS PAINTING
AN ATHLETE BUT ALL THEY CAN
DO IS STICK FIGURES.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IS HE BETTER AT DOING THIS
THAN EVERYBODY ELSE.
I WOULD SAY HE IS ADEPT AT
IT BECAUSE HE LOST THE WORD
ADEPT.
>> Jesse: HE LOVES THAT.
>> Gregg: I DID FEEL
WATCHING THIS I WAS AT RUTH
CHRIS BECAUSE THERE WAS SO
MUCH RED MEAT.
THAT'S THE AUDIENCE.
WHEN YOU ARE GOING TO CPAC
YOU GIVE THE RED MEAT.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS, HE'S
INTERESTING AND FUNNY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD USE SOME
OF THAT.
>> Jesse: VERY GAINING,
>> Jesse: VERY EAINING,
>> Jesse: VERY ENTNING,
>> Jesse: VERY ENTERNG,
>> Jesse: VERY ENTERTA,
>> Jesse: VERY ENTERTAINING.
WE THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FUNNIER FOR A DIFFERENT
REASON.
WE ARE LAUGHING AT THEM NOT
WITH THEM.
HE WAS THERE TO TOUT HIS
ACCOMPLISH.
S AND ALSO FIRE UP THE BASE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A BASE
ELECTION AND TRADITIONALLY
THE PARTY IN POWER DOESN'T
DO WELL.
DO YOU THINK HE CREATED ANY
MOMENTUM FOR THE BASE.
THERE, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Jesse: IN THE LARGER
CONTEXT?
>> WELL, YEAH.
HE HAS -- THE THREE BIG
THINGS, THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
HE IS GOING TO POINT TO ARE
TAX REFORM AND THE ECONOMY.
THE JUDGES.
>> Jesse: YEP.
>> Dana: FOR THIS CROWD IN
PARTICULAR.
AND THEN I THINK HE WOULD
SAY SECOND AMENDMENT
PROTECTIONS.
THAT'S NOT REALLY A
PROACTIVE THING THAT HE DID.
>> Jesse: THEY LOVE THAT.
>> Dana: THOSE ARE THE THREE
THINGS THAT HE KEPT
REPEATING.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH A
PERSPECTIVE THING LIKE ROOK
AT ALL THE THINGS WE ARE
GOING TO DO THIS YEAR IN
2018.
BECAUSE THERE IS REALLY
NOTHING THAT THEY ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE AGE TO GET DONE.
I DON'T THINK IMMIGRATION IS
GOING TO GET DONE.
I SAW JOHN CORNYN.
I OUT A STATEMENT SAYING
RAISING THE AGE OF WEAPONS
OF 21.
GETTING A WEAPON TO 21.
YOU ALREADY SEE THAT
APPEALING OFF IN THE SENATE.
SO THE PERSPECTIVE THINGS
AREN'T GOING TO WORK.
BUT, TELLING THAT CROWD THAT
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN,
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE AWAY
THE TAX CUTS, THEY'RE GOING
TO TRY TO TAKE AWAY THE
JUDGES THAT YOU HAVE, AND
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO
REPEAL THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
SO YOU BETTER GO OUT THERE
AND VOTE.
THE ONLY THING ABOUT THIS
SPEECH AND I SAID THIS A LOT
IS THAT I FEEL LIKE HE COULD
DRIVE A NEWS CYCLE BETTER IF
HE CHOSE ONE THING TO DRIVE
NEWS ON AT THE TOP OF THE
SPEECH, LET THE NETWORKS AND
ALL THE REPORTERS COVER THAT
PIECE, AND THEN MOVE ON TO
DO THE REST OF THE SPEECH
BECAUSE EVERYTHING GETS
LOST.
IT'S LIKE BEING AT RUTH
CHRIS WITH FIVE COURSE MEAL
AND I COULDN'T EAT IT ALL.
>> Jesse: BIG NEWS I THINK
WHAT YOU WOULD SAY IS THE
NORTH KOREAN SANCTIONS HE
LEFT TO THE VERY END.
I THINK HE MIGHT HAVE ALMOST
FORGOTTEN HE WAS GOING TO
BREAK THE NORTH KOREAN
SANCTION NEWS THERE WAS SO
MUCH OTHER STUFF.
HE SPOKE TO REPORTERS BEFORE
HE EVEN GOT TO THE EVENT.
AND I SEE WHAT YOU MEAN
ABOUT DLIEWGHT THE MESSAGE.
JUAN, WHAT WAS MOST
OFFENSIVE PART OF THE
SPEECH?
>> Juan: SEVEN YEARS TO GO.
[LAUGHTER]
FOR AN OLD MAN YOU ARE
RISKING A HEART ATTACK.
>> Dana: ARE YOU GOING TO
MAKE IT?
>> Juan: SEVEN YEARS TO GO.
THE CPAC AUDIENCE WENT WILD.
SO THIS WAS A RALLY.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE AND I THINK HIS
STAFF THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE SOMETHING ABOUT
INCREASING SANCTIONS ON
NORTH KOREA.
AS YOU SAY, HE HAS KIND OF
GOT TO IT AT THE VERY END.
BUT AS AN AFTER THOUGHT.
HE WAS FAR MORE INTERESTED
IN TO PICK UP ON THE STEAK
HOUSE ANALOGY OF THROWING
OUT THE CHUNKS OF RED MEAT
EVERYWHERE HE TURNED.
I WAS SURPRISED THAT HE WAS
THROWING OUT CHUNKS THOUGH
THAT HAD TO DO WITH THINGS
LIKE DEMOCRATS ABANDON DACA.
I'M THE ONE WHO CARES.
WAIT A MINUTE, HE IS THE ONE
WHO ENDED DACA AND SET THIS
MARCH DEADLINE.
NOW HE FINDS HIMSELF IN A
SITUATION THE DEADLINE IS
APPROACHING AND HE HAS GOT
NOTHING.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
WILLING TO TAKE A RISK.
I HOPE THEY ARE HAVING A
LITTLE MORE SPINE THAN THEY
DID LAST TIME WHEN SCHUMER
BACKED OUT ON THAT BUDGET
DEAL.
AND THEN THIS BUSINESS ABOUT
LOCK HER UP.
JESSE, IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY, GREG, I SAID A
1970S HIT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH THAT.
BUT HE STILL.
>> Greg: IT'S HIS FREE BIRD.
>> Kimberly: OLDY BUT A
GOODY.
CLASSIC ROCK.
>> Jesse: SNAKE.
>> Juan: IT'S LIKE HE IS
GOING BACK.
HE NEEDS A HILLARY.
HE NEEDS AN OBAMA.
BECAUSE HE JUST NEEDS
SOMEBODY TO BE --
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY, I THINK
EVERY POLITICIAN HAS A
BOOGIE MAN OUT THERE,
WHETHER IT'S AT HOME OR
ABROAD THAT THEY USE TO
SCORE POINTS AGAINST.
AND HILLARY CONTINUES TO BE
OUT THERE IN THE
CONVERSATION.
SO WHY NOT TAKE A SHOT?
>> Juan: SHE LOST.
>> Jesse: SAY THAT AGAIN,
JUAN?
>> Juan: SHE LOST.
GET
.ET
>>T
>> Greg: LIKE GROUND HOG DAY
FOR HER.
>> Juan: YOU LIKE PELOSI.
>> Kimberly: THAT ONE, TOO.
HILLARY IS LIKE THE BOOGIE
PERSON.
>> Jesse: I STAND CORRECTED.
>> Kimberly: YEAH.
BUT THE CROWD LOVES IT THEY
LOVE IT THEY'RE LIKE OKAY,
LOCK HER UP, THEY GO CRAZY.
HE DOES HAIR STUFF.
SO THIS IS LIKE CLASSIC
QUINTESSENTIAL PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THIS IS HOW HE SPEAKS.
EVERY TIME HE GETS UP IN
FRONT OF SOMEBODY IT'S A
RALLY OPPORTUNITY.
>> Jesse: YEP.
>> Kimberly: HE OBVIOUSLY
DID VERY WELL WITH THE CROWD
THERE THEY LOVED HIM AND HE
LOVES THEM BACK.
>> Jesse: HE SAID THAT AT
THE END.
HE SAID I LOVE YOU GUYS.
YOU HAVE BEEN TO CPAC,
RIGHT?
>> Gregg: I SPOKE
>> Greg: I SPOKE THERE FIVE
YEARS.
WE HAD ONE THING THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE MONTAGE,
EXPLAINING WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER YOU WIN AN ELECTION.
YOU JUST WON IT AND A YEAR
LATER IT'S REALLY HARD.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANY
PRESIDENT EVER SAYING THAT
THAT'S HUMAN PSYCHOLOGY
ONE-ON-ONE.
HE WAS EXPLAINING WHY YOU
LOSE IN TWO YEARS IN A WAY
AT PEOPLE AT HOME
UNDERSTANDS.
OH, IT'S SO MUCH WORK YOU
ALREADY WON.
THAT'S THE BEST SO
PERSUASIVE, I THINK.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT ME LIKE
I'M FROM OUT OF SPACE.
>> Juan: THIS LOOKS HOW
UNPREPARED IS HE FOR THE
JOB.
NEVER BEEN A CONGRESSMAN AND
SENATOR OR GOVERNOR.
OH THIS IS REALLY HARD.
WHO KNEW HEALTHCARE COULD BE
SO COMPLICATED?
TO ME THIS IS SUBJECT OF
RIDICULE.
>> Greg: AT LEAST THAT'S
HONEST.
>> Juan: HONEST, OH MY GOSH.
>> Dana: WORKING ON POLICIES
GOOD FOREVER
GOOD FOR OER
GOOD FOR OUR OPPONENTS.
MAY NOT REALIZE THOSE
POLICIES ARE GOOD FOR THEM
BUT WE ARE DOING IT ANYWAY.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS
EFFECTIVE.
>> Jesse: SAID A FEW NICE
THINGS HE SAID ABOUT KEEPING
HIS PROMISE.
HE BRAGGED OBVIOUSLY, THE
ONLY POLITICIAN THAT'S
ACTUALLY KEPT MORE PROMISES
THAN HE MADE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK BACK,
BESIDES THE WALL, A LOT OF
THE STUFF HE HAS DELIVERED
ON AND THE AUDIENCE REALLY
ENJOYED THAT.
>> Kimberly: THEY DID.
HE IS A MAN OF THE PEOPLE
EVEN THOUGH HE IS A NEW YORK
BILLIONAIRE.
HE'S RELATABLE BECAUSE HIS
LANGUAGE, HIS RHETORIC ISN'T
LIKE FLOURY. FLOWERY.
IT'S DOWN TO EARTH.
SOMETHING FOR EVERYBODY
THERE THIS IS MY GUY.
HE IS NOT TRYING TO TALK
ABOVE ME.
NOT TRYING TO TALK AROUND
ME.
MAKING ME FEEL LIKE I'M HERE
FOR YOU.
WE HAVE GOT THINGS IN
COMMON.
I'M GETTING IT DONE.
THAT'S LIKE A REASSURING
FEELING.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE TYPICAL
POLITICIAN WHERE YOU GO I
CAN'T RELATE TO THAT PERSON
AT ALL.
>> Juan: CAN I PLAY SKUNK AT
THE GARDEN PARTY FOR A
SECOND?
>> Kimberly: BE YOURSELF.
I CAN SMELL FROM HERE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE PROMISED
TO DO AWAY WITH OBAMACARE.
>> Jesse: MANDATE IS GONE.
THE MANDATE IS LONG GONE,
JUAN.
JUAN
>>AN
>> Juan: OBAMACARE IS REAL
SCOTT WALKNER JOHNSON
THINKING ABOUT GETTING OUT.
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T SEE ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING, NO.
>> Jesse: IF DEMOCRATS COULD
COME TO THE TABLE, JUAN, YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY GET SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT I PROMISE
TO CUT THE DEFICIT.
THE MINUTE I GET IN THERE E
OH.
>> Jesse: JUST WIND ISIS OFF
THE MAP.
HOW ABOUT THAT PROMISE.
>> Greg: AMAZING DEMOCRATS
CARE ABOUT A DEFICIT AND
TRUMP DID THAT FOR THEM.
WHAT KIMBERLY AND DANA AND
JUAN SAYS THE PRESENTATION
IS AN OLD SCHOOL POPULIST.
GETS UP THERE AND HE IS TELL
YOU THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO WHEN YOU PULL
BACK THE REASON WE HAVE
DISAGREEMENTS ALL OF YOU WAS
DO.
ALMOST EVERYTHING HE DOES IS
COMMON SENSE CENTRISM.
HE TALK PRESIDENCY ENFORCED
BORDER AND 1.7 MILLION
PEOPLE.
TALKS ABOUT GUN TALKING
ABOUT POPULAR PROACTIVE
SOLUTIONS THAT SOME THE NRA
MIGHT NOT LIKE.
TAX REFORM, IF PEOPLE THINK
THAT REALLY HELPED THE RICH,
THEY'RE WRONG.
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE OTHER
THING HE DID TODAY IT WASN'T
IN THE CPAC SPEECH BUT IN
HIS PRESS CONFERENCE WITH
MARTIN TURNBULL.
HE TALKED BRIEFLY BUT IT WAS
INTERESTING INSIGHT INTO
THAT HE IS GETTING THE
BRIEFINGS AND HE UNDERSTANDS
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN SYRIA.
AND HE SAID IT WAS
DISGRACEFUL.
250 INNOCENT PEOPLE THAT WE
KNOW OF WERE KILLED TARGETED
BY RUSSIANS AND SYRIANS AND
WE HAVE A HUGE MESS ON OUR
HANDS THERE THE ONE THING
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND IS
HE SAYS THAT BUT ALSO IN THE
SAME SPEECH OR IN THE
PREFERENCE HE SAYS, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE DEGRADED ISIS.
WE HAVE TAKEN OVER THEIR
TERRITORY AND WE'RE OUT OF
THERE.
THAT IS NOT SUSTAINABLE.
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS CANNOT
BE TRUE U GOING FORWARD IN A
SECOND YEAR OF A PRESIDENCY
YOUR FOREIGN POLICY PIECES
GET REALLY IMPORTANT AND
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO DEAL
WITH.
>> Jesse: ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> Juan: BEFORE WE GO, IT'S
KIND OF A SERIOUS NOTE THERE
ARE STORIES NOW THAT
INDICATE THAT THE RUSSIANS
WERE IN TOUCH WITH TOP
LEADERSHIP BEFORE THEY
ATTACKED.
>> Dana: IT'S THE SAME GUY.